bonsoir à tous nous sommes le lundi 27
juin vous regardez le 7 8 le journal
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition tout de suite les
titres
quelles conséquences après le break site
pour le territoire la sortie du royaume
uni de l'union européenne inquiète les
citoyens mais aussi les entrepreneurs
reportage réaction et explications avec
notre invité de ce soir olivier chanut
ex responsable du centre d'information
europe direct de la maison de l'europe
des yvelines et les vacances sont pas
encore officiellement commencé mais il
faut déjà penser à son logement pour
l'année prochaine samedi l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
organisé la cinquième édition du forum
logement
les api sont de retour à plaisir ces
animations au pied des immeubles sont
une tradition dans la commune où elle
existe depuis 2011
l'initiative pour cultiver le vivre
ensemble et favoriser les liens entre
plaisir oit pour nous en parler ce soir
ginette faroux adjointe du maire à
l'action sociale délégué aux familles et
aux solidarités viendra nous en parler
et nous ouvrons ce journal avec cette
information les premiers délégués du
gouvernement ont été nommés et ont pris
leurs fonctions rappelez vous le 26
octobre dernier
depuis les mureaux été lancée le comité
interministériel pour l'égalité et la
citoyenneté afin de renforcer la
présence de l'état dans les quartiers
les plus en difficulté à trappes pour le
secteur des merisiers et de la plaine de
neauphle c'est olivier van d'art anciens
proviseurs de lycée et ancien inspecteur
d'académie dans le val d'oise qui a
officiellement pris place au sein du
collège gargarine il a pour mission de
favoriser l'éducation
l'accompagnement personnalisé vers
l'emploi la mixité sociale dans le
logement ou encore l'accès aux droits et
aux soins des plus démunis siens et
nouvelles informations nous en parlions
la semaine dernière valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france
avait évoqué en l'absence d'accord pour
financer le pass navigo à tarif unique
d'augmenter le tarif à 80 ou 85 euros
l'augmentation est aujourd'hui
officielle le prix du pass navigo
augmente de 3 euros un protocole
d'accord a été signé entre l'état et
avec la région ile-de-france pour
résoudre le problème
du financement du forfait navigo ce
dernier passera donc à 73 euros dès le
1er août soit une hausse de 4,2 pour
cent et dont cette édition nous parlons
du bric site abréviation de britain et
exit les britanniques ont voté jeudi 23
juin à 51,9 % des voix pour sortir de
l'union européenne et à 48,1 % pour le
reste et 17,4 millions de personnes ont
donc voté pour le break site le premier
ministre britannique david cameron qui
avait organisé chez la tenue du
référendum mais avait fait campagne pour
le maintien et suit donc un très large
revers et a annoncé sa démission
prochaine vous en parler avec nous notre
invité ce soir olivier gêne ou ex
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors je le rappelle
vous êtes responsable du centre
d'information directe de la maison de
l'europe des yvelines qui est situé à
saint germain en laye alors pour bien
comprendre cet événement qui est un peu
historique donc au niveau de la fia
échelle européenne quelles sont les
raisons qui ont poussé les britanniques
a procédé à ce référendum alors tout
simplement alors c'est un fait c'est un
fait qui est connu que les britanniques
ne sont pas très europhile à la base ils
ont toujours été pour une conception
l'accès aux marchés c'est toujours ce
qu'il a c'est toujours ce qui les a
intéressés ça toujours été l'axé
économique au marché unique le
développement des autres politiques ça
les a beaucoup moins intéressé et il se
trouve que monsieur cameron lors de lors
de sa lors de sa campagne pour la
réélection en tant que premier ministre
avait notamment promis aux britanniques
que s'il était réélu il organiserait un
référendum
justement sur l'appartenance du royaume
uni au sein de l'union européenne
il a été réélu donc il a il a tenu sa
promesse et donc à effectuer ce
référendum est ce que je non c'était
plus pour des raisons financières
cédaient plus aussi pour des raisons
liées peut-être aux formalités de une
formalité de l'union européenne que vous
quel tous les pays sont imposés
alors justement ça c'est un gros point
de débat qu'il ya eu pendant la campagne
effectivement le beaucoup disent que
l'union européenne c'est compliqué ça
impose beaucoup de ça impose beaucoup de
réglementation donc c'est vrai que c'est
un point qui a joué c'est vrai que ça a
des points qui a joué dans cette
campagne
ce que voulait monsieur cameron en fait
c'était négocier un meilleur accord un
accord spécifique pour le royaume uni
pour qu'on va dire qu'ils puissent avoir
le beurre et l'argent du beurre sans
avoir à subir les conséquences négatives
de l'union européenne alors finalement
on a beaucoup parlé du bric site voilà
au moment où ça a été votée mais très
peu avant ça arrive assez rapidement
est-ce qu'on s'attendait à une telle à
une telle décision à la sortie du
royaume uni bah en fait c'est que si on
suit bien si on a un peu suivi
le bric site en fait oui parce que ça
fait quand même depuis trois ans que
monsieur cameron a dit qu'il allait
faire ce référendum
donc en fait c'est pas une surprise du
tout la campagne a duré plusieurs mois
la campagne a été longue la campagne
elle a été quand même assez rude et en
fait quand on regarde même les arguments
que chaque camp a mis dans la balance
finalement en fait on avait le camp du
riz mène donc ceux qui voulaient rester
dans l'union européenne c'est en disant
il faut pas sortir il faut pas sortir
parce que sinon ça va être pire et le
camp du justement le camp du break site
qui lui avait des arguments un peu plus
sensationnel il chiffre est un peu plus
en disant ben voilà on va récupérer une
souveraineté nationale on va plus être
dépendant de bruxelles
on va on va financer davantage nos
sécurité sociale donc en fait aussi sur
le cieux sur les arguments on va dire
que le camp du bric site a sorti des
arguments un peu plus
qui touchait un peu plus le coeur et en
fait non on peut pas être trop surpris
durée on peut pas être trop surpris du
résultat qu'on a bien suivi il est ce
que finalement la classe politique
française s'est exprimée très largement
alors que il s'attendait à une telle
décision
non la classe politique française pas
trop alors ça a été préparée quand même
ça il faut pas qu'il faut mais il faut
pas il faut pas le nier mais on va dire
qu'au feu au fond de soi ils attendaient
tous il s'attendait tous à ce que le
royaume uni reste alors dans les
yvelines
les élus ont également réagi à cet
événement valérie pécresse donc
présidente de la région ile de france
parle d'un pré sident calamiteux et d'un
coup de tonnerre sur l'europe en
encourageant une réponse franco
allemande
elle en profite également pour faire un
petit coup de pub à la région
ile-de-france en invitant les
entreprises qui souhaitaient rester dans
l'union européenne à venir s'installer à
paris le président du sénat gérard
larcher parle lui d'une mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'europe
il appelle à relancer le projet européen
a sollicité le président pour tenir un
débat parlementaire et cela le plus vite
possible
de son côté le conseiller régional yves
les noix et dieye tu sais dit inquiet
tout comme benoît hamon député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines qui se
posent la question du changement pour
l'union européenne plus proche de nous
jean michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
tweet ceci le couple franco allemand
doit se renforcer d'urgence lors du coup
c'est c'est normal pour les électeurs
locaux en vue de s'inquiéter ce que je
vais avoir des répercussions directement
peut-être sur notre territoire
effectivement faut bien comprendre que
alors les répercussions en fait vont
vraiment se faire sentir lorsque le
royaume uni sortira officiellement de
l'union européenne pour le pour le
moment le royaume uni n'a toujours pas
activé ce qu'on appelle le fameux
article 50 la fameuse clause de sortie
donc le royaume uni est toujours un
membre officiel de l'union européenne on
nie toujours 28 c'est qu'à partir du
moment où le royaume uni pas
effectivement sortir complètement donc
que l'ensemble de la législation
européenne ne lui sera plus applicable
que là on va sentir effectivement les
véritables conséquences notamment
économiques pour les entreprises qui
essaye justement d'exporter royaume uni
alors d'un point de vue économique
justement les conséquences ne se sont
pas fait attendre vendredi 24 juin au
matin le cac 40 a perdu 8,0 4% dans la
journée les investisseurs sont dans
l'incertitude la livre continue de
chuter face à l'euro alors dans les
yvelines certaines entreprises possèdent
une activité de l'autre côté de la
manche alors qu'elles vont être
justement les conséquences pour elle je
vous propose d'en parler juste après
avoir visionné ce reportage de nicolas
d'andré bréxent it is coming et pour
l'entreprise ip software le regard est
tourné vers sa filiale britannique
cette dernière s'occupe de
commercialiser au royaume uni les
produits de la société conçue en france
et la chute de la monnaie britannique
pourrait avoir des conséquences
on verra après dans un en fonction de
l'évolution
tout simplement de la livre si l'on doit
nous augmenter notre tarification par
mais on sera malheureusement obligés
aussi en tout état de cause de te tenir
compte de nos concurrents sur place pour
faire en sorte que notre offre reste
effectivement compétitive cette société
édite des logiciels et propose des
prestations de services informatiques
20% de son chiffre d'affaires provient
du marché britannique
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
qu'effectivement que nos produits
restent dans le coup du marché par par
ce qui se pratique sur ces territoires à
partir de quoi l'instance jeux et jouets
il n'y a aucune raison à ce que demain
matin votre développement en soit
directement impactés je pense que la
relation établie entre l'angleterre la
france ne se trouvera pas directement
impactés je pense que l'impact va être
surtout pour davantage pour les anglais
en termes effectivement de kout
économique que pour
nos relations commerciales et la
conversation avec son partenaire anglais
se veut rassurante tant qu'on n'a pas le
plan de sortie
je pense qu'au niveau effectivement de
la monnaie bon voilà ne peut pas plus je
bouge et que ça bon il ya la certitude
c'est certain le royaume uni a deux ans
pour négocier sa sortie de l'union
européenne pour l'entreprise yvelinoise
et sa filiale anglaise l'activité se
poursuit en restant attentifs aux
indicateurs de l'économie britannique
olivier jennex vous venez donc de voir
le reportage économiquement aussi on
peut s'inquiéter ou alors il faut
attendre on est encore dans le flou
alors là on est complètement en fait
dans le flou effectivement comme le
disait la personne dans le reportage
il faut attendre concrètement l'accord
qui sera négocié entre non seulement le
royaume uni et l'union européenne est
aussi possiblement un accord spécifique
qui sera négocié entre le royaume uni et
la france
il ya fort à parier que si effectivement
le royaume uni décide de couper toutes
les frontières
ça va poser
ça va poser notamment pour nous quelques
soucis concernant la circulation des
personnes
est-ce qu'il va falloir un visa est ce
qu'il va falloir qu'on est ce qu'il va
falloir un visa est ce qu'il va falloir
un passeport donc ça il risque dit il va
certainement y avoir des accords plus
spécifiques entre pays ce qu'on appelle
des accords bilatéraux qui vont essayer
un peu de qui ont essayé de clarifier
cette situation
la dernière question avant de terminer
cet entretien on parlait d'un autre
référendum pour voilà être sûr de moi du
choix donc dû des onglets est ce que
c'est possible
est ce que ça changerait quelque chose
alors juridiquement c'est possible pour
resituer rapidement dans le contexte
quand une pétition déposée sur le site
du parlement britannique atteint un
certain nombre de votes
les parlementaires britanniques sont
obligés de l'examiner et d'en débattre
en séance a donc juridiquement c'est
possible politiquement ça serait
compliqué voir ça serait un suicide
politique pour certains conseillers pour
certains députés britanniques merci
beaucoup olivier genzel venue sur le
plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions nous suivrons cette actualité
avec vous faut autre sujet le secrétaire
d'état chargé de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche dire
immonde on était cet après midi à saint
quentin en yvelines
il a visité les installations
équipements rénovés de challenger
l'occasion de présenter des projets
innovants au service de la pédagogie et
de qualité de vie dans le campus de
demain écouter le les têtes au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude parce que
notre système d'université à deux
mutations énorme à conduire premièrement
on doit révolutionner la façon
d'apprendre la pédagogie ça passe par le
numérique est ici dans le campus
connectés dans le savoir-faire du campus
connectés de bouygues ya ces
technologies là qui sont domestiqués
deuxièmement nous avons en termes de
stratégie immobilière de faire des
locaux à la fois confortables
accueillant hospitalier une nouvelle
façon d'apprendre et en même temps
respectueux de l'environnement aussi un
autre défi et je trouve qu'il ya pas de
mille visites plus approprié que celle
ci pour voir des expériences concrètes
de réussite de la transformation
numérique de la pédagogie
et de la transformation durable de
l'immobilier et parlons logements
étudiants à présent ce samedi
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines organisé la cinquième
édition du forum logement au programme
ateliers sur la fiscalité rédaction d'un
contrat ou encore atelier sur la loi
allure pour les étudiants objectif les
aider à trouver un toit
regardez ce reportage signée manon labat
et camille lambert
la cinquième édition du forum logement a
inauguré la nouvelle maison de
l'étudiant le crous a réuni une
quinzaine de partenaires des comités
locaux et des propriétaires l'objectif
réunir tous les acteurs du logement et
les étudiants qui sont à la recherche
d'une habitation pour la rentrée sur
saint quentin en yvelines
je recherche un logement pour ba
pourrait être proche de les muter mais
donc on est venu ici pour avoir à peu
près une seconde chance par rapport à ce
qu'on avait déjà choisi pour elle c'est
avoir un choix
le contact que l'on a eu dans un premier
temps avec le crous était des plus
agréables et nous a permis d'avoir donc
l'information sur le
sur le forum et le fait d'avoir accès à
bon nombre de renseignements de
rencontrer des
darphin les gens ont des personnes
différentes avec des solutions proposées
d'ailleurs différentes que ce soit de la
colocation par contre est-ce qu'on
partira ce soir avec un logement chance
et historien l'accès au logement pour
les étudiants est de plus en plus
complexes des professionnels et des
associations contactées par l'université
étaient présents pour guider les jeunes
et leur famille c'est compliqué le
logement il y a plein de choses à savoir
il ya des mécanismes à comprendre
on est là pour expliquer au public
comment ça fonctionne et les démarches
qu'il faut faire j'irai les démarches
auto adaptées à leur situation
les jeunes viennent avec des projets qui
sont parfois un petit peu déconnectés de
la réalité
on est là pour leur explication les
ressources des territoires et comment
tout ça fonctionne c'est vraiment de
l'accompagnement individualisé avant de
prendre un logement les étudiants
doivent toutefois attendre les résultats
du bac
prenons la direction de trappes à
présent le centre emmaüs ce qui est
située dans la ville de trappes de se
trouver de nouveaux locaux est situé de
son 1 avenue des bouleaux emmaüs trappe
et en fin de bail sur le bâtiment il
n'est plus possible de venir faire des
dépôts de prendre rendez vous pour un
ramassage malgré la fermeture le 30 juin
l'association restera en activité ou le
monde des bureaux pour rechercher un
nouveau site est dédié à la vente
aucun dépôt ne sera possible durant
cette période on écoute le responsable
du site nous donner plus de détails sur
cette fermeture c'est un bail précaire
qui avait été mis en place au mois de
janvier 2015
dans l'objectif de d'acheter le bâtiment
à l'issue du bail précaire et puis pour
un certain nombre de raisons notamment
financières cet achat n'a pas pu
ce faire on a prolongé le bail précaire
de décembre 2015 jusqu'en juin 2016
et puis maintenant le propriétaire ne
veut pas le prolonger donc on fait une
petite pause en espérant redémarrer fin
2016 dans un domaine dans un
établissement et nous allons à plaisir à
présent avec notre seconde invitée de ce
journal en plateau avec nous une étape
phare ou bonsoir à vous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes adjointe au
mal à nos mères de plaisir déléguée à la
famille et aux solidarités
alors vous êtes ici pour nous parler des
api les animations au pied des immeubles
qui ont lieu donc toute cette semaine
jusqu'à vendredi
alors elle existe depuis 2000 2001 je me
suis peut-être trompé dans mon lancement
voilà c'est existe depuis 2001 alors
voilà comment ça va se passer qu'est ce
qu'on va y trouver toute cette semaine
et bien ce qu'on va y trouver alors déjà
ça sera une animation qui sera organisé
par les animateurs et les responsables
des centres sociaux maintenant qu'ils
s'appellent maison des familles et il ya
il y aura également des services de la
ville ainsi que des associations qui
sont caritatives ou culturelles ou
sportives
donc demain premier jour de lancement
sur le quartier de la haise qui est
proche de la gare de plaisir grignon
ensuite ce sera sur le quartier de
l'aqueduc sur le parc des quatre saisons
puis aussi le quartier du val hibou et
enfin la journée de clôture
le goûter en fête de clôture qui aura
lieu sur la maison des familles de la
mosaïque alors c'est 16h30 à 19h30
relais
les horaires le but donc c'est de se
faire rencontrer tous les plaisirs roi
voilà d'améliorer le vivre ensemble
alors c'est d'améliorer le vivre
ensemble est également du tice de tisser
du lien entre les voisins parce que vous
pouvez avoir des personnes qui habite
dans le même immeuble et qui ne se
connaissent pas donc effectivement c'est
important de créer ce lien mais il ya
également des gens des quartiers voisins
qui viennent sur ces animations alors ça
s'adresse à tout le monde
ça s'adresse complètement à tout le
monde du plus jeune au plus âgé
alors cette année à une spécificité que
vous aviez déjà fait l'année dernière
donc des animations autour du cirque là
aussi c'est pourra favoriser les liens
ajustement entre les habitants alors
c'est pour favoriser non seulement le
lien entre les habitants mais également
entre les parents et les enfants puisque
comme vous le savez très certainement le
jeu donc le cirque est un jeu également
puisqu'il va y avoir des ateliers le
cirque et le jeu crée du lien et des
interactions entre des parents et des
enfants qui ne sont pas forcément
habitués à jouer toujours ensemble c'est
avoir un événement très convivial qui
s'adresse à tous ça s'agace un sketch de
monde dans une dynamique globale de à la
ville voilà pour pour les habitants pour
instaurer juste peut-être un meilleur
climat
alors non parce que le climat est bon le
climat est bon mais c'est justement pour
que les gens puissent se rencontrer
puissent échanger avant de partir en
vacances
alors justement un pour partir en
vacances il ya aussi des gens qui ne
partiront pas en vacances et pourrait
également
alors bien évidemment qui a des gens qui
ne partiront pas en vacances
sachez tout de même que au niveau de la
ville et notamment au niveau du des
maisons des familles nous organisons des
séjours familiaux et là cette année ça
va être au bord de la mer très bien
merci beaucoup donné de la voix si on
veut retrouver voilà tout toutes les
animations de se rendre sur un site
internet de la ville
il ya tout voit tous les horaires on
peut se renseigner ainsi voilà savoir à
quel moment on peut y participer
tout à fait et d'ailleurs je voulais
dire que ces horaires là 16h30 19h
n'était pas choisie par hasard c'est
justement pour qu'il y ait le plus de
monde possible puisqu'il ya des gens
évidemment qui travaillent et voilà
alors vous avez entendu le message venez
nombreux aux animations au pied des
immeubles et me retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site internet de la
ville merci beaucoup à ginette à faro
j'ai vu remercie tout autre sujet euro
2016 à présent l'équipe d'irlande qui
avait pour camp de base de versailles
est rentrée chez elle ce lundi après sa
défaite contre l'équipe de france en 8e
de finale après avoir été mené 1 à 0 les
bleus ont su rebondir pour l'emporter 2
1 en deuxième période grâce à un doublé
d'antoine griezmann match évidemment été
très suivie dans les yvelines dans le
barreau paris à versailles une centaine
de supporters maquillée déguisée aux
couleurs de la france s'est réunie pour
regarder la rencontre dans ce club
irlandais les fans nous donnent leurs
pronostics pour les prochains matches de
l'équipe de france on les écoute
j'espère oui j'espère que la pauvre elle
est long j'espère qu'on va gagner ça me
ferait du bien au moral à tous mais
j'espère et je pense que si on se
rencontre l'allemagne bon on va se faire
manger comme d'hab comme duncan allemand
d'habitude peu de choses ouais plutôt ça
passe maintenant mais pas plus jamais
sur un malentendu et du foot nous
passons au basket on va prendre la
direction des parcs et américains
l'intérieur français gershon ya buzzell
qui a pour agent élan pour toi olivier
mazet de l'agent sam à sport agency
vient d'être sélectionnée pour intégrer
l'équipe mythique des boston celtics
vous le voyez à l'image le sportif de 2
m 01 % 21 kg a été retenu en 16e
position au premier tour de la draft
américaine pour jouer en nba
une grande émotion pour son agent
yvelinois ont l'écoutent
il ya de multiples sentiment est qu'il
abhorre évidemment énormément de joie et
de satisfaction parce que c'est une
draft relativement historique
on parle d'un septième choix au premier
tour savoir quelques quatre joueurs qui
ont fait mieux dans l'histoire du basket
français
et puis le dernier sentiment c'est aussi
une vraie source de motivation parce que
voilà c'est un sahour des perspectives
on a d'autres projets à très court terme
de draft 2 du même du même acabit donc
voilà c'est c'est un mélange de joie de
satisfaction de fierté motivation et
cette information concernant la piscine
andré pierre viénot de guyancourt elle
sera fermée à partir d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'à dimanche 3 juillet cela afin de
permettre aux équipes techniques de
réaliser des travaux d'entretien comme
la vidange annuelle des bassins tant
mieux qu'ils ne fassent pas si beau
temps elle retrouvera lundi 4 juillet de
11h à 13h 30 et de 14 heures 15 à 20
heures en semaine et de 9h à 13h et 14h
à 19h le week end et les jours fériés
chiens et vous avez peut-être eu la
chance d'y participer ce week-end
l'hippodrome de longchamp accueilli
concerts débats et expositions pour le
festival engagé à solidays la région et
la première partenaire de l'événement en
participant à hauteur de 800 mille euros
avec 80 concerts répartis sur 7 scènes
la programmation était une nouvelle fois
riche et éclectique
retour sur cet événement festif avec
fanny brouillon et williams à elle
trois jours de fête et de lutte contre
le sida solidays est revenu en flammes
et l'hippodrome de longchamp ce week-end
pour sa 18e édition record de
fréquentation cette année avec plus de
200000 spectateurs les attaques chez la
souris ou encore oxmo puccino offert in
et musique et solidarité
je suis très fier des de participer à la
solidarité sida pour pour maintes
raisons en plus de la cause parce que
les gens qui travaillent à
l'accomplissement de de ce projet ce
sont des gens puisque puisque
merveilleux c'est ça qui est sublime
c'est que devant la noirceur d'une cause
qu'on défend verrait lumière des gens
qui se battent contre ce confort enfin
cette maladie
les têtes d'affiché n'était pas
seulement présente sur celle de
christiane taubira à bill gates
des personnalités de tous bords sont
venus partager leurs convictions
treize conférences se sont tenues au
forum café dont celle du moine
bouddhiste matthieu ricard
c'est bon enfant c'est sympa et son
gentil et tout est avec l'idée de se
mettre au service d'autrui
dès que ça commence à faire des trucs
égoïste ça marche jamais tout le monde
est de mauvaise humeur
là la bienveillance c'était un cirque un
cercle vertueux spirale vertueuse plus
on est bienveillant plutôt monde est
heureux on est en reçoit mais nous on
est gagnant
entre deux concerts les festivaliers ont
aussi pu découvrir l'exposition engagé
i'm with m2 anna r la photographe
redonne une identité aux migrants
qu'elle a suivi de lesbos à munich
c'est important d'abord parce que c'est
180 mille jeunes qui vont regarder
ezzeldine bouchra et l'âme et n'avoir
que c'est important qu'on dise aux
réfugiés
nous savons que vous êtes là et vous
êtes parmi nous vous êtes déjà parmi
nous et nous devons vous regardez et
vous accueillir parmi
solide elle cette année c'était aussi du
sport ce dimanche après-midi montchamp
s'est transformé en fan zone le temps de
retransmettre le match france-irlande et
de fêter une qualification tricolore et
vous retrouverez à partir de mercredi
sur notre chaîne une émission spéciale
consacrée aux soldats is de 13 minutes
et animé et préparé par william l c'est
à présent la fin de cette édition je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis
restez avec nous tout de suite on va
parler sport avec michael et demi
d'euros dans le site sport entouré de
ses invités
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
une nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite donc une excellente soirée si
ça demain
il